welcome back to from the point by your
favorite Point another episode presented
by Sprite winter spice
cranberry um back here Bleacher Report
again with my guy
Winston oh uh and then got my longtime
friend uh best friend probably in the
NBA uh I mean played a with each other
now NBA champ Michael Porter Junior mpj
my brother what's up
up we got to come up with the uh the
handshake too yeah we got to get the
handshake we got we do that every
episode yeah I think we got to start
showing people backstage first so nobody
thrown off facts but I mean recently uh
so we I seen you at the the inseason
tournament game yeah uh in La y'all
played the next day pulled up with Floyd
my boy uh how was that like what was the
game like uh how'd you pull up with him
what was it like yeah man I mean first
of all like I was hot because I wanted
to play in that tournament um you know I
thought the inseason tournament overall
was was a success for the first year um
it went a lot more smoother than we
thought I think we needed one more win
to secure the spot so I just we played
the Clippers the next day um and so I
just pulled up to the game Floyd hit me
and and that's why I wanted to pull up
with him and uh yeah just went kind of
just just went to watch the game it's
different s court side like watching
when you're not like on the bench it was
a whole different experience um but you
know like like you said Floyd a cool
dude real uh real down to earth you know
when I'm with him I just like to ask
some questions like how have you been
great so long um how have you like how
do you take care of your body um I just
pick his brain bro so it was a good
experience chilling with him course side
for sure yeah that's a that's a good
point Mike um Trey I know you pulled up
to a playoff game last year um you kind
of started to touch on it a little bit
but how was that experience um shoot for
you whenever you know most of the times
you don't pull up to NBA games as a as a
fan but as a as a player in the game so
what what was that experience like for
you oh it was it was clean I was
watching well I went to two I went and
watched Steph play oh yeah you did go to
two Steph play LeBron and then I went
and saw him play LeBron I just be in LA
in the summertime so that's just a time
oh yeah just out there just just you get
to just train but it was just a
fortunate time I got to watch him the
last time I went I went and saw when the
Warriors played the the rockets in the
Western Conference Finals after our
rookie year and it was like it's
different like you said it's different
watching it and being in it like you
like you see things that you could have
done that that would have been different
and then the it looks sometimes more
physical from just watching the game
like just watching the game it looks way
more physical than when you're in it and
I'm like that's a weird thing too like
yo these dudes are super fast like they
cuz cuz I think when you're when you're
about to play and you're even on the
bench you're already ready to play
you're ready to get out there so you're
already like in the most to play when
you're just over there chilling in your
street clothes yeah you're like yo these
dudes are moving fast like it's
crazy um Mike first of all man congrats
on winning the championship this year
bro that's that's so major um we were
actually we recorded episode probably it
was earlier on the summer I think it was
right after you won and um Trey uh Trey
I you had made a comment you were like
man I'm I'm just jealous of Mike man I
just want to be in the finals so bad man
uh but seriously like during those uh
that that time those conversations that
you were having with Mike what were
those conversations like and and how did
those conversations motivate you to get
back to the playoffs and eventually go
get you a championship man watching him
was like I mean motivating like jealousy
is just love and hate at the same time
so it's like jealousy isn't necessarily
a bad thing all the time like I we joke
about it being jealous like that's like
my brother I was pulling for him we we
communicated every now and then
throughout the playoffs like he knew I
was pulling for him and so just seeing
him like achieve a chip the stuff that
we talked about since traveling around
the the country playing uh basketball is
like it's cool to see and it's obviously
motivating for his brother to want to go
do the same thing and so I mean and I
know he wants to do the same thing and
get another one so it's just motivating
for for each other to keep doing it so
it's cool what about you what was that
what was that time like for you man
hadn't been to the hadn't been to the
finals before how was it well man like
tracing back to even college and not
being being able to play in college like
I was looking at Trey and seeing what he
was doing and like he said like I was so
happy for him seeing what he was doing
at Oklahoma but part of me was like man
like I want to be out there too like he
was motivating me to get back on the
court and so even my rookie season um
seeing him when they would come play in
Denver and he's just killing us like I'm
like man I cannot wait to get out there
so when he talks about kind of that
jealousy aspect I feel that because I
was I was looking at him the same like
way like when I couldn't play and so you
know we we made it to the Western cover
finals in the bubble um but it was
nothing like when you get the the arena
full of fans you know and all that so I
remember watching him in the uh Eastern
Conference Finals you know out of New
York and everything like that um and
just watching his whole playoff run and
that whole and how that went and that
motivated me you know so then we went to
the finals like I was just so it was
just it was a crazy experience because
the the Western Conference Finals was
one thing but then to make it to the
finals it's a whole another like yeah
level up from the from the media
attention from just the pressure of the
games like you're so close to winning an
actual championship and so like Trey
said man we were communicating um he was
telling me stuff he saw in the games you
know just telling me to go get one and
uh man just what I've been through um
individually and then to you know fall
in the draft to Denver it's crazy that I
think I'm the first guy in our draft
class really to uh y to to win a
championship so
I mean God works in mysterious ways so
it was just it was Unreal and you know I
think we got a little bit of The
Hangover right now we're not really uh
as sharp or as motivated right now as a
team but man that was that was a
incredible incredible run no that was a
that was a crazy run um was there a time
in the in the finals that you knew like
okay this is over like cuz y'all I mean
in the finals y'all did y' St I mean
even leading up then like was there time
in the playoffs or was there time in the
finals that you're like okay yeah we
going to win it I'm not going to lie bro
like we felt so dominant like in the
playoffs like I think our hardest series
was probably Minnesota in round one or
Phoenix in the second round when uh you
know dbook and KD were going crazy so
you know then we played the Lakers we we
swept them and even though they were a
really good team by the time we got to
the finals um and we saw we were
matching up against the Heat we kind of
knew we had them like before the series
even started we just knew matchup wise
and obviously the heat are very Scrappy
they're a really good
team we we we couldn't figure out how
they beat the Bucks we couldn't figure
out how they beat Boston um so I think
Boston overall matched up with us a
little bit better than the heat so I
think from man from the very beginning
we knew if we took care of business
having homec court advantage you know
playing in the altitude yeah if if we if
we took care of business we kind of knew
um we we we could get a ring that's fire
that's fire how is uh how's life been
since then how's life been off the court
how's life been even on the court yeah I
mean I
think I mean not much changes of course
everywhere you go it's congrats champ
it's it's amazing the support you get
you know everyone just referring to you
as champ that's really that's really
dope that's how I was getting referred
to all summer I did a little bit of
traveling went to Taiwan um it was crazy
to see the fans over there halfway
around the world like I landed at like 4
4:00 a.m. and the whole airport is just
filled with with fans and I'm like it
was crazy they all just had telling me
congrats and and things like that um the
only other place I really got to travel
was to the Bahamas for your wedding just
because the offseason was so short cuz
we won the championship so that was the
only downside I would say is the
offseason was so short but overall man
like life has been good I think once you
get there and we've always been winners
you know like back to high school we've
always been winning championships you
know we won with Team USA W with mocan
so I'm used to winning so I mean the NBA
Championship is different but it's
really just the same we're we're winners
we're addicted to winning so it's not
like you can let your foot off the gas
um I was right back in La trying to get
better you know this summer um playing
with you some and and that's really what
it is I mean you just until you put your
shoes up put the ball up you just
continue try to get better and we're
trying to do it again this year so so
this can uh this can kind of be a
question for the both of you
um what what do you what feeling lingers
the most winning or getting knocked out
I know my answer right off the bat I
mean it's losing like I have like PTSD
and like Trauma from that sun series
when they swept us I think it was the
year before and they swept us uh I think
Jamal was hurt I got hurt like the first
game and we got swept and it was just
like so to get them back last year it
was good but that's that man when you
lose especially like in an embarrassing
manner that's sticks with you for sure
no for sure for sure I think I think man
I used to be like that like it's crazy
like I used to be I used to be like that
like I used to just be I used to hold on
to my losses way more I don't know
something about just having kids it just
makes you like appreciate moments more
you know what I'm
saying you know it makes you just
appreciate like the better things more
and I think not saying I don't I don't
hold on to the the L that I take or hold
on to the the losses because I trust me
like I'm the first one to tell you I'm
like I'm I hold on to that more than
anything so I remember everything but
it's like I also remember the good times
and like cuz like when you when you
leave the arena you're somebody else too
so you can't be mad all the time and and
and feeling down or a certain way all
the time so when you said that that's
that's the first thing I comes to my
mind like that's just the competitor in
you and that's just the the beast that's
just in us and the winner that's in US
but it's like something like some
sometimes things change you bro and it's
like I feel like just having kids is
made me see just hold on to certain
things maybe a little bit more and just
appreciate and just makes me Chase more
happy memories than just holding on to
certain grudges I've heard that actually
like I I've had teammates before who who
have kids and the way they handle their
losses or whatever is so much different
than the guys that don't like we we're
we're stuck in the locker room we're
we're you know probably pouting we're
reflecting on the game man they're
they're hitting the showers whatever
it's time to go home and be a dad and
and even if you lose you got your family
to go go back to chair you up I feel
that for sure no it's a totally
different feeling bro yeah y'all talk
about amazing holding you know
cherishing on to those amazing things um
I think one of the most amazing things
that the NBA is grateful for is y'all's
draft class for sure like you said
you're the only uh I think you're the
only player as of now to win a
championship but um y'all draft class is
stacked man
um we uh We've to obviously Trey and I
were close during his draft process but
what was your draft process like I'm
sure it was pretty different from from a
lot of other guys that were going
through that year um you know walk us
through kind of what your draft process
was like and and how you just kind of
stay ready and and prepared for what was
eventually where you're at now yeah man
honestly my whole draft process was like
depressing because I was wanting to work
out I was wanting to travel and work out
with teams but I wasn't right yet you
know know dating back to college um
that's when I first got injured actually
Trey remembers this pretty clearly like
the the time when I really like messed
up my back remember I tried to dunk and
practice Austin I'm talking about I
tried to boom on this dude and I fell
from way up here I thought I died like I
fell on my back and what happened was I
didn't take enough time off so my back
kept nagging me all the way into college
um to where you know I had to get the
surgery and what happened was I came too
came back too soon to try to play in the
play uh the it's not even called the
playoffs NCA tournament yeah I tried to
come play back in the uh NCA tournament
came back too soon and my back wasn't
fully healed so I kind of reinjured it y
so the whole draft process bro like I'm
not able to work out like I want to I'm
trying to get my back right and it's
just depressing man because I'm seeing
all these dudes kill it and like
whatever so what happened was I me and
my agent decided to have one pro day we
were going to invite all the teams in to
watch me um you know go through it so I
I hadn't really been working out a whole
lot but I took some anti-inflammatories
and I'm like okay I'm I'm going to go
show them what I can do worked out
pretty well didn't miss too many shots
and I remember like teams were pretty
impressed cuz they hadn't seen me for a
while yep and the Sacramento Kings at
number two you know they met with me
they were like man like we really like
you like we might take you at number two
because they thought I was fully healthy
um so my agent hit me and was like we're
going to do one more pro day in front of
the top 10 teams because there's a
chance you might go number one like you
know they all thought you looked healthy
and that was the biggest question mark
so I'm hyped but at the same time my
back is still bothering me so I remember
the day before that second pro
day um like I couldn't get out of bed
like my my back spasmed up that bad that
I couldn't get out of bed and I called
my agent I'm like bro like I don't think
I can even I don't even think I can go
work out like all these teams flew in
and everything so I'm I'm like scared
because this is my whole future ahead of
me you know what I mean and so we
decided to let all the team doctors like
look at me so instead of the pro day I
go to the gym I'm laying on a table and
all these doctors are just analyzing me
and I know I'm not right you know I'm
it's just like it's a traumatizing
moment like I know I'm not right but
there's nothing I can do about it and so
I'm trying to fake it like I'm not in
pain on the table you know trying to
fake like I'm all right meanwhile I'm
I'm I'm hurting so the Clippers doctor
was the one who um and I I don't really
hold a grudge but I know who it was the
Clippers doctor is the one that wrote up
the report you know once they all
analyzed me it was like he'll he'll
probably never play again like that's
how bad my back was
um and so yeah so then I don't even know
how my agent really finessed it to where
team was willing to take a chance on me
after reading that report that the
doctor read I think the Nuggets were
just like man his upside is is pretty
high even if we got to deal with the
injury let's let's try to at least
figure it out
so man we go to New York for the draft I
see name after name go by dudes that I
think I'm better than and I'm sitting
there in pain I'm watching all these
dudes get
drafted and then get drafted to Denver
man and like at the time it was it was
not how I viewed the NBA draft going for
me I always since high school viewed
going up there you know one two three um
and so that was tough to go 14 it was
like a hit to my ego hit to my pride but
even then I'm like man I don't even know
if I could hoop so fly to Denver you
know how that goes after you get drafted
and they do their whole
analyzing and you know I really even
talk about the story a lot but I really
didn't know if I was going to hoop again
like but they got me right took the year
off first year and started playing my
second year and it's been a it's been a
journey since then you know a lot to go
through but looking back especially
after the Championship those are the
times you reflect you're like man God's
God's fingerprints were somewhere in
this story you know what I mean that's
an amazing testimony bro thank you for
sharing that that's awesome yeah I mean
shoot you really you really went through
went through everything in your D draft
process and honestly we've talked about
this too but how important that draft
process is to mold you for your future
no matter what the circumstances are it
could be a humbling moment could be
something like that so um I'm so happy
that it worked out for the both of y'all
man that's no I mean and it's it's crazy
too I mean this is just not the rip like
he
just Talent alone Mike should have been
top three draft like in our class it's
not even like it's not even a debate
like the reason he failed at 14 is cuz
people questions like and people don't
understand like really that's why he he
he got paid the way he did like people
know the talent he has like and him
being a third option just brought them a
chip like he can really bring more it's
just it's just dud it's about situation
it's about being like people believing
in you so it's really cool like to to
hear how how it all I mean really worked
out for you in the long run to be honest
with you fact now you too cuz I remember
watching you in the in the summer league
and like you were struggling at first
but people I remember I put a little
video on Snapchat I think like bro like
stop talking crazy about Trey because
they were they you know how people are
they see it's recency biased so they saw
the summer league they're like man he
might struggle in leag I'm like no watch
like he's going to kill and then I think
you were second year in the league you
were an All-Star starter like one of the
best point guards in the league um led
the league and points and assists like I
feel like you out of anyone in our draft
class are severely underrated like
you're one of the best players in the
NBA and so and you're right it is about
situation like you've been lucky enough
I remember even back to and I know I'm
just talking right now but like I
remember back in in high school you text
me you like bro where should I go to
college like you think I should go to
Kentucky or Oklahoma I'm like n Trey go
to a team that's going to let you be you
and go Dominate and then you went to
Oklahoma and did your thing and it's
been the same thing in the league with
the Hawks you know you got an
organization that believed in you you
and you've been killing ever since bro
so it's been fun to watch well I
appreciate it did y'all ever talk about
teaming up in college did we yeah we
were going to he had me he had me
thinking he had me putting Washington on
my on my final list y'all were about to
go to Washington together no he was
never going to come to Washington I I
decommitted from Washington like I got
him to at least put Washington in like
his top 10 maybe but like I remember I
decommitted from Washington and I was
likey should I go to Missouri should I
come to Oklahoma he kept saying Oklahoma
but I was trying you know they they hir
my dad in misso so I had to go back home
yeah you made the right decision but
let's go since we talking about a let's
go let's go to it I know uh it's a lot
of debate always I'm in the locker room
always debating our team like do do you
ever getting heated conversations about
Au like with teammates where do you
where do you rank us where do you do you
ever have conversations I do um because
like Aaron played on a really good team
Oakland soldiers um who else played
there's a few guys but we got a lot of
young dudes um they be showing so I
think oh yeah they showing the
highlights yeah N I always tell him no
this the best a team ever and the only
reason I say that is because bro in the
in the peach jam which is the
highest like place of basketball biggest
tournament ever we were smacking teams
by 30 every game like we didn't win the
championship by 10 points we went by 30
you know what I mean and then besides me
and you we had probably the best
basketball coach I've ever really like
been played under you know Coach P was
amazing then you got all the role
players jonte you got Jared Ritter we
had your brother jonte like you said we
had man we were cold bro Elijah cardier
Gordon this is where
you Brian Trimble I know you wasn't
throwing lobs to me in high school so
yeah yeah no I mean I had to save my LOB
throwing for this I was a serious lob
threat back in the day I was about to
say that's more lob threat than I could
have been the world I mean
my age our age we know the the live
threat Mike is like the world really
don't ain't seen it ain't seen it yet
and it's been yeah you know injuries you
got to change your game bro but I used
to be like bounce punching stuff and I I
think I seen a clip where y'all posted
on the
podcast where people have qu uh
questions if Trey can play with like a
superstar he was like man like I play
with Mike in high school we were a
dynamic duo like people don't know how
willing of a passer he is he would
rather pass score he can just go get 40
or 50 cuz he's that good but really he
he would he would have a layup you know
and might throw it off the backboard and
I'm catching it and windmilling like
he's always been such a willing passer
which I think uh you know people know he
can pass but that's definitely an
underrated part of his game for sure I
mean yeah there were some there were
some really really good aou teams I've
got one here 1994 New Jersey Patterson
aaou team that team had Kobe Bryant
Vince Carter Tim Thomas Rip Hamilton and
Kevin Freeman the So-Cal all stars of
2005 and 2006 Kevin Love Brandon
Jennings Chase buinger Taylor King and
Daniel Hackett um they only lost two
times in two years what circuit did they
play on though like that's what I'm
saying I you don't did they even play on
a circuit I don't know if they had Circ
is like that I mean that's not like e
eyb though that was like some something
totally different I feel like um Kobe
you said Kobe and Vince play together
yeah and rip pamilton
I a't going lie
um there was an indie Heat team in in
2004 with Greg Odin Mike
Conley 51 Jeff Teague and andan cook we
still winning though cuz Greg golden
back then um yeah who guard GRE dominant
B Roy like Brandon Roy will tell you
Greg golden was like dominant BR Roy was
your coach of high school right yeah how
was that experience for you man BR Roy
like he let us Rock You Know besides
moan you know my my high school team
Nathan
hill we we went to Seattle I moved to
Seattle and it was the uh the worst team
in the in the Little League there you
know we went there um BR Roy decided to
be the coach and we went undefeated
number one team in the country beat
teams like Sierra Kenyon you know oakill
remember y'all were nice no we was nice
uh BR Roy was a big part of that he's
one of those dudes I don't think he
really played for like a players coach
like that like a dude who used to play
in the league or like but they give you
a whole different type of confidence
like B Roy was Mike no if you're hot and
you come past half court and you feel
good hesi somebody from from half court
he was really telling me that so that's
why I was killing so much of Nathan H
was because of BR Roy that's fire who
was uh on that moan Squad who was one of
the most underrated guys on your team
that I think Jared Ritter I'm G
say Jared Ritter had a strap man he his
role was to shoot wait and then we had
that backup PG that backed you up Elijah
would have some timely buckets too he
would have some time he had some timely
buckets
man Elijah L from Tulsa yeah from Tulsa
oh yeah man we I mean we had a squad for
sure everybody went d one yeah like high
major only one the lowest was probably
army guy named uh Connor went to Army
Conor my my fault
Conor light skinn that's just crazy bro
uh man man dang I can't believe that was
the low the lowest offer I mean it's
very clear that like you guys but we had
like okay so we had him M Missouri
Oklahoma oh yeah
Conor SMU J Witter went to
Xavier I mean we had yeah and then like
Jon's in the league right now cardier
could have went to the league I don't
know really what his situation is yeah
Brian was dumb athletic Florida State
I'm saying we had a squad um but what do
you think about today so now you got a A
Team I got one what do you think about
like today's a like do you think it's
different like well first of all I have
my opinions on it but what do you think
about it well first of all what happened
when our a teams played each
other but we smacked them
boys but I think we don't need that's
that uncalled for bro no he got a squad
I think we played him back the next year
and his team got better in beat ours but
I think uh uh how is it
changed I don't know I think I mean my
team isn't on the circuit um but it's
really just is good I I know you feel
his way too is like being able to give
back to these kids really and just like
from areas where we're from and bring
kids together um my team is in the
middle of Columbia Missouri so you got
the St Louis the Brad Bill team over
here you got mokan and KC so it's hard
to get good kids but even just the just
giving back bro is the main the main
thing I like about having a team it's
it's hard it's hard to compete getting
kids when competing with them I had to
deal with that same problem man but
aren't y'all like one of the best teams
in the y'all love one of the best teams
one of the best teams in Adidas in
Adidas I mean we we about to have our
first pro you know Jobe Walter plays for
B I heard the name he uh is a fresh
about to be about to be a top player
he's about be my first draft pick so and
then doesn't your little brother play on
the team too he's on like the the 13 U
team so that's fire so it's cool like
you said just to give back and just have
kids bro that's I mean like be able to
give back and hopefully have kids make
it to the league is cool um I agree so
people uh if I'm not if not not mistaken
Mike in high school you uh you went to
Steph Curry's Camp um and you wanted to
be PE that camp man what what what was
that like for you I remember seeing
highlights cuz uh my invite must got
lost in the mail or something I didn't
get that invite but uh I don't know if
they but um but what was that experience
like for you and um man just getting to
learn from somebody like that who I'm
sure at the time it's probably still is
is like you know one of the players you
look up to oh yeah um I think that year
Steph was was like unanimous MVP so I
mean I was super hyped when I got the
invite um I think you were going to go
but you were more of a Nike dude at the
time right yeah yeah you were at the
Nike Camp I think I went there and uh
missed out on like a a Nike trip they
did in the Bahamas or something but
working out with Steph I mean you know
you you just kind of see the work ethics
so from a young age like that was
imprinted on me like how good this dude
is how how he prepares how he works out
and it just kind of carried me through
um to the league like I'm always trying
to learn little things like even you
know playing with Joker now like I'm
trying to learn little things on how you
can achieve greatness so that was my
first experience really being around a
superstar like that and I got to take a
lot of take a lot of things in um but
yeah I think the the GU the camp was for
a lot of guards and I was like a bigger
guard at the time so me and uh you
remember Billy Preston we were the
biggest dudes at the camp
so uh yeah like one-on-one drills and
things like that like I was nice too I
was winning a lot remember yeah Billy
was Billy was nice yeah um you've
obviously worked out with Steph a lot um
this summer the previous summer um this
is a question for both of you guys but
what what has your been your biggest
takeaway from him either the way he
works or kind of the certain things you
guys get to work on during those
workouts man it's I think it's pretty
simple a lot of people say the same
thing just the speed in which he works
and like the conditioning part like I
mean you just feel more in shape when
you leave a workout like you just feel
like you just accomplished two three
workouts in that hour that you spent
with them like and it could be simple
drills as far as just shooting layups
going full court doing two ball
dribbling and just touching lights and
little things like that it could be
simple but it's just the condition and
how fast you go that's when you learn
like that how this the pace and which
you like practice really really matters
and affects and how you play too what
about you Mike yeah like he said it's
the pace and like the uh I think step's
greatest ATT is like his uh how how good
a shape he's in like Trey said like he
got a trainer named Brandon Payne um
amazing trainer but like those are the
workouts in my whole life that when I
leave those I feel like I got better
like I come back to the gym the next day
I'm like oh like my handle feels tighter
like I don't feel as tired running like
so he works at a completely different
level than I think uh anyone I've seen
really works it is there uh we in we in
year six right like we in year six now
it's
like you don't
really we play our Idols but it's not
like the
same like feeling like how do you feel
when you play like your guys like I mean
we used to go KD sponsored our a team
like I know you you looked up to him and
the way he played and and all that like
how's it feel now like you've played
against him some years you've even been
in I mean play off battles with him like
how how's it feel going up against some
of your idols and yeah I think it
definitely takes a year or two to kind
of kind of get rid of that kind of
mindset of like man like I'm guarding KD
or KD is guarding me like I really want
to go at him right now like and you
don't really have that cuz but it's in
the back of your head like man this dude
is a superstar LeBron KD Steph all these
guys that we grew up watching I think it
took me like a year to kind of just view
it as um we're on the same court he's
going to me I'm going to him um but I
mean you still admire their game like
even though I'm trying to go at these
dudes or whatever you still admire their
greatness you still respect them there's
certain guys you don't talk trash too
yeah um and you just respect what
they've done in the league so there's a
ton of guys like that for sure so you
know y'all talk about y Idols y'all talk
about matchups too somebody's checking
the ball up right now one-on-one who's
winning between y'all too him yeah1 to1
21 you better ask him we play we play
Since y'all have been Pros yeah it gets
sick for
him all right we ain't played since
we've been Pros no we we've only played
at moan like in moan and and that wasn't
fair
though why wasn't it fair though why cuz
there was no rest one we play one he got
bro he be fouling you be fing be fouling
to be honest we never really like
checked it up like let's go 100% we play
like at the end of practice and uhle d
and just couple we only do like two or
three dri so obviously I have the
advantage if we're doing unlimited
dribbles and he can do all this crazy
stuff like I don't know but I mean he
we're different positions you know so I
don't know how that would go now I mean
if he gets hot he's going to be hard to
stop if I get hot I'm just shoot over
him and it's gonna be hard to stop me so
it's goingon to be
tough that's fair he's saying the humble
rout if if there's no cameras in here
he's saying he beating me and I'm
letting him know I'm beating him facts I
mean it would be back in high school
like I think I was at the time the
number one ranked player and he I don't
know he was you know there was a lot of
guards yeah mid 20s but he always would
tell me Mike I want you to know like I'm
the number one player in the country
you're the number two player in the
country so yeah off camera we definitely
got a little a little competition going
on it' be it'd be all right game it's
all healthy it may go it may go if we
went seven games it may be three
four for sure my way Mike I know you uh
taking a little bit of pivot here but we
obviously got started this summer with
from the point know you got your own
show curious Mike man how's that how's
that process been like for you starting
your own podcast finding your own voice
um I know you just had an interview come
out with ag um one of my favorite
interviews honestly of all NBA podcasts
honestly I I'm a huge fan of AG so just
talk talk about what podcast has been
like for you and yeah I think um
similarly to Trey like I think uh it's
easy as an NBA player to get
misunderstood as a person you get you
know people see how you on the court
they see you in your competitive nature
or whatever or even like in we're in
2023 so you know people send out tweets
they post on Instagram write a caption
and it's super easy for the world to
perceive you a certain way or like to be
taken out of context and for me like I I
sent out a couple tweets it's about
certain situations in the world that I
that I wanted to speak on or whatever
and you know right now in the world we
living if you don't go along with like
the social Norm like you get killed for
it on social media so for me the podcast
was just a place where I can talk openly
about situations I want to and I can
like uh kind of show who I am as a
person but really just openly talk and I
named it curious Mike so it's like a a
humble way of saying I don't know
everything but I still want to talk
about certain things and I don't I don't
need people taking me out of context or
taking one tweet I said and and blowing
it up so for me it's been good I just
get to have people on there Trey's been
on there we got to talk about you know a
lot of stuff um but it's just a a
passion off the court you know a little
a little hobby I like to do off the
court yeah what about you I mean we're
now this will be our 11th what what
about you I mean just reflecting over
the past 10-11 shows man I mean he he
hit the nail in the head a lot of the
same reasons it's more about just trying
to find ways to control your your own
voice sometimes when you talk to the
media two three times a day every other
day it's like sometimes your words can
get misconstrued or uh you don't really
can't really say everything you want or
don't really have everything that you
want to say on your mind right then so
like having this platform it gives us an
opportunity we can really I mean just
get on it and we can we can speak our
mind and speak the truth and then also
people get to know the real side of us
and get to I mean see more of the
authentic I mean side of us and and what
we what we see and what we go through so
absolutely speaking of AG man there was
this hilarious video this summer about
him and yic in Serbia in the summer and
they was like as some horse race or
whatever like you gota be honest bro
like is this is this dude really like
obsessed with horses y yeah man this
dude like this dude he definitely likes
horses more than basketball that's
that's that's the best way to put it
like man we'll be in there getting ready
for practice at training camp whatever
and he's on his phone watching the horse
races and then that's who AG is as a
person you know he's the ultimate
teammate he uh he's a Carefree dude
he'll travel in offseason by himself so
I know he pulled up on jok and uh I know
they had a good time out there in Serbia
so I mean you know they're just they're
both like one-of a kind dudes Joker all
offseason is in Serbia drinking beer and
watching horses like he probably didn't
touch a basketball all offseason and
somehow he got better and then AG is
just he's a great teammate he uh he and
he's just a free spirit so he went he
pulled up uh to Serbia so I think I'm
going to try to get out there next year
um and see what yoke has going on so you
definitely go yeah I want to go check it
out just see the culture out there he
tells me like it's fun out there he says
the night life is way better than it is
over here so I'm going to go turn up
with
J I feel that I feel that what what is
uh I mean playing with a guy like as
dominant as him like you've told me you
told me some stories before about how
easy he he makes it seem but I mean what
what is it like playing with with the
guy as Domin is joking I mean like I've
played with good passers like I play
with you I play with you know jonte you
know my brother who's obviously a very
good passor he makes the game super easy
for me um so I played with really good
Playmakers and pastors I think from the
like the center position the way that
joker you know can get it in the post
teams come doubl and now he's finding me
open all the way across the court for
open threes or he's finding me on a cut
you know I feel like the two people have
benefited most from how Joker plays with
me and Aaron because Aaron's getting all
these easy lobs you know and playing
playing out of the dunker spot and when
teams come double he's throwing it up to
Ag and then me I'm getting just a lot of
easy wide openen threes I I mean I don't
know how he's so good like I don't he
over the years his routine has gotten
like better and better like when I first
came in the league he wasn't that um
like locked in but now man every day
he's on time he's probably you know the
first one to the gym getting his
treatment in he's he's religious about
his routine and it's just crazy to see
people see like his demeanor on the
court and it's like oh he's just kind of
nonchalant but he is like he's on it so
I think I just try to learn his work
habits really and his routine and how he
approaches the game um but he's he's you
know the best player in the NBA and um
man he probably could win MVP the next
four or five years the way he plays like
m i mean it's crazy he puts up sh do
every night easy it's crazy I know I
know you had said at one point that at
first you were uh you were surprised
that yoke was starting over Mason
plumbley yeah um at what point were you
like never mind like you know what like
he is actually very much him because
like the Nuggets were the last team I
thought I was going to get drafted to
like I I barely knew the Denver Nuggets
were an NBA team like so I get drafted
there and they're telling me like they
got this big dude who's really good but
you know how it is in college like we
pay attention to the NBA now but we
really were paying more attention to
college mhm so I didn't really know how
good Joker was but people around the
organization kept telling me how good he
was we get out to training camp and you
know Mason's a pretty athletic big so he
was just you know catching lobs dunking
running the floor and Joker just
wobbling around like not really caring
nonchalant and he's not really killing
in training camp but they're like no
just wait wait till you see when he
actually wants to he could score 40 a
game if he wants to I was like man
there's no way and then we get to the SE
season and he's going crazy like one
game he'll have 20 rebounds the next
game he'll have 15 assists the next game
he'll have 30 the next game after that
he'll have all those combined like and
I'm like bro what's going on and then
the craziest part about him is every
year he's gotten better like he was the
MVP then he got better and became the
back-to-back MVP and he's better like
today than he was then so it's just like
I don't know how to describe the dude to
be honest minus minus him is uh is he
the best passer in the world
uh it's it's it's it's different like
he's you know I think there's a few
passers that amaze me when we play I
think Trey because I've always said like
because of his size and the way he's
looking people off and throwing the lob
and getting it over the like the arms of
longer Defenders it's is really crazy to
me and then you know I think Joker I
think Luca the way like you know Luca
will look off a defense and then dime
somebody and now Tyrese like I'd say
like I don't know if I'm missing anybody
but to me those are the four Dudes that
like kind of amazed me with the passing
yeah what you think no I mean I I think
he said the the the ones that come to my
mind I mean Luca be passing that like I
feel like if I was 68 like Luca is who
ID I'd be like you know what I'm saying
like as far as scoring as far as passing
like we do the same like look off like
if there's look off to the corner
swinging it from one side of court to
the other corner I just don't get how he
does it being your size though it's just
like I got to I got to get that's why I
have to use my speed to get through gaps
and and I got to get to more creases but
that's why also I get some deflected
some deflected and some turnovers that
way too cuz I'm also always trying to
find find people but sometimes it gets
deflected that way but what's been the
favorite pass that you've ever caught
from him going all the way back to high
school man there's so many we we
connected on so many lobs like man ah
man my favorite one I think it had to
have been peach jam
Championship I you know he knows like he
he also knows his players so he knew
like I had have a big game if we wanted
to win we played a stack team Mo bomba
Quade Brandon Randolph uh I think they
had a few other really good players yeah
H Hassan uh yeah Hass the the Lefty he
was nice but I missed my first shoty was
on that team Cole Anthony and so I
missed my first shot and I think we
either got an offensive rebound or we
went down and got a stop and then we got
the ball again but Trey you know
dribbles the Gap and just finds me for a
quick dunk I think I dunked on like Mo I
didn't like like Mo jumped pass me I
dunked it that was the first points of
the game but he just knew like okay now
Mike is probably rolling he's feeling
good and just to know your players and
know your personnel like I think that
was a big one just because that was the
Peace Jam Championship I don't know if
you remember I remember I remember that
I remember that play I think I just
remember like it's hard to remember one
play cuz we made so many like yeah if
you look back at our at our highlights
it's like we made so many plays and then
even in tournaments that people it
wasn't even it wasn't ebl it was just in
Kansas City like we had so many moments
just I mean I can just thinking of times
throwing it between my legs back and
letting him run and we're in a small
little gym just full of Kansas people
and yeah people are just going crazy
like we have so many moments and like
just that was that was a fun time I got
to learn how to like I can be a really
good play and still play with somebody
really good too and like we can do some
really good things so yeah you guys have
so so much history on the court off the
court um NE kind of reflecting on that
what's one thing that you guys were
grateful for getting to team up with
each other have that experience in high
school I remember just from my own
personal experience with Trey obviously
I didn't meet you until recently but um
man this dude would Rave about you all
the time bro i' be like dude this dude
Mike is like one of the coolest people I
know so I know there's a lot of history
and a lot of admiration there between
the two of you guys but what's that uh
what's like one thing that you guys been
grateful for for each other throughout
this process yeah well I remember first
meeting Trey at the Nike 100 Camp I
think it was in St Louis St Louis and
like we both were kind of late bloomers
so we're both like kind of like not as
grown as the other dudes in our class
you know they got mustaches beards we
and I remember seeing just this scrawny
kid who was a really good point guard
but then like I was playing on mokan the
year before he
came and you know we did all right but
like we weren't that good and so we
needed to go get a point guard and then
our our a guy named Matt Suther who's
kind of like the GM in NBA terms of of
moan he's like man we found this dude
you know he's coming to practice
whatever his name is Trey young and I
had heard the name but I couldn't put a
face to the name then he walked in the
gym the next day I I remember him then
we got on the court and like he had
gotten so much better but like he took
our team to a whole like another level
like we I don't even think we made Peach
to the year before he came and then he
came and we both were young we were
playing up so we were playing guys like
dear Fox Jason Tatum but we made peach
jam that year and we were competing and
then the next year you know we won it
but that's what I remember is just I
finally got a point guard who who you
know we had the chemistry off the court
we was going to you know our coaches
cibb and spending the night when we had
the three days in Kansas City and we
just grew a bond like we were trying to
sneak out the crib together you know we
just young dudes and then um grew that
relationship after that no that's that's
facts everything you said was facts I
mean thing I remember most is just like
obviously the road trips like me and him
were together for so long one time we
ended up just fighting just had to fight
it out like we just he was paus tackling
me on the bed like we was in a hotel
room like yeah it was like we had spent
so many weeks and weekends with each
other from USA to peach jam to all the
camps and everything we was in the same
room and we had just gotten so tired of
each other little things was just making
us so mad and I just remember those
times and so like that's why we Brothers
to this day and so it's it's really cool
man that's awesome man but before
hilarious but before we wrap um there's
a uh there's a clip that's been going
around um did uh did Luca emulate your
shot man overnight I don't know if he
was trying to emulate my shot but it
looked like it though uh I seen that oh
he may have cuz he like jumped up and
shot at yeah I saw that uh
I think a couple of my teammates sent it
to me and then I seen the comments they
was like ah if he emulate Michael
Porter's game like he ain't gonna get no
assist no
more so that had me weak too um but
that's funny because he shoots it like
he just barely jumps so I saw that clip
and it was pretty fun definitely
imitating you n but it's a few dudes
that shoot like that um in the league
like doesn't bons maybe maybe bons
Burtons jumps like cam Thomas jumps on
his jumper um but you you the I mean you
got think you're the best yeah I'm the
I'm the OG dude that like I yeah I jump
on my jumper and to get it off yeah for
sure that was a funny clip that was
hilarious though I was like I can't wait
I know we're sitting down with mpj soon
so I we got ask him about that no for
sure well appreciate my brother coming
again uh on the show um it's been
another episode of from the point by
your favorite Point catch us on
bleaching yes sir bleach all season long
till till next time my guys peace
appreciate y'all boys man y y have some
good questions thanks
[Music]
bro